two people are dead after a small Alaska
based Airlines third crash in less than
a year the float plane crash yesterday
is the second deadly incident for Taquan
air in just a week the plane went down
in the water near Ketchikan Alaska mola
legi shows us the safety concerns Mullah
good morning
well good morning Anthony the National
Transportation Safety Board is
investigating the cause of the crash
which killed the pilot and the only
passenger on board it says the tequan
float plane but was on a commuter flight
the company also conducts sightseeing
tours a plane carrying tourists was
involved in a mid-air collision just
last week you might remember that six
were killed and ten people were injured
in July of last year all eleven on board
another two Kwan Air sightseeing plane
had to be hoisted to safety after the
pilot became disoriented in cloudy
weather and crashed into a mountainside
six passengers were seriously injured in
that crash since 1994 two Kwan Air has
been involved in at least nine accidents
resulting in 15 deaths the airline
directed us to the NTSB which said while
it is unusual for an operator to have
two accidents in a short period of time
that alone does not imply there's a
safety issue with the company their
pilots or their aircraft Tony
unusual indeed molla thank you very much